[Music]
history on book tv
barbara freeze tells the story of how
coal has altered the course of human
history
this talk from ruminator books in saint
paul minnesota is an hour
all right
if you wonder
where books like this come from
i'm here to tell you they come from
somebody with a sustained obsession
and i of course have been
obsessed with coal for quite a long time
but i want you to know that i have never
lost sight of the fact that to most
people coal
is a pretty boring topic it's a pretty
unlikely topic for a book and i cannot
tell you
how many conversations i've had that
have come to a screeching halt at a
party or something when somebody will
say oh you're writing a book that's so
exciting what's it about and i say
cole
and
i get a lot of blank faces and a kind of
silence and response and um
uh you know some people are just
incredulous or just not sure they heard
it right so they'll say c o a l um
i think the best line was from a man who
said cole
would that be porter or slaw
[Laughter]
he actually knew better but it was it
was still a great line
so i want to assure you that i did not
write this book for people with a
pre-existing interest in coal though if
you happen to have one
that's great but i wrote this book for
people with no interest in coal for
those people who got that blank look on
their face
people who don't think they're
interested in coal but who are
interested in the world and in how it
got to be the way it is and in what
might happen next and of course there
are a lot of ways you can look at those
issues and a lot of the books in this
store do that but coal it turns out is a
particularly revealing way to look at it
how did i get interested in coal i get
asked that question a lot as you heard i
was an assistant attorney general here
in minnesota for a number of years and i
focused on environmental regulation i
helped among other things enforce the
air quality laws
in the mid 1990s there was a particular
proceeding here in minnesota an energy
planning proceeding where we tried to
quantify in dollars and cents the
environmental cost
of generating electricity we in
minnesota get most of our electricity
from coal that's in fact true of the
nation as a whole and it is why in fact
modern america burns more coal much more
coal than at any other point in its
history
well i
just broke the
i'm
podium
to restore it for the sake of
ruminator is that what it says
all right
or maybe not sorry
ayah
i thought that this proceeding was going
to be a dry sort of technical and boring
affair
and it turned out to in fact be
a
really enormous and extremely
contentious proceeding and the reason
that happened is because we
didn't just look at acid rain and ozone
or the health effects of coal from the
kind of traditional pollutants that
people are used to worrying about we
looked at climate change that was a
subject that i personally had never
spent any time worrying about before but
it was a subject that we couldn't ignore
by the mid 1990s and it was something
that struck a very sensitive nerve with
the coal industry representatives of the
coal industry of course we don't have
one in minnesota but we buy our coal
from out of state
came to minnesota they intervened in our
proceeding they ended up helping to make
it one of the longest administrative
trials in state history
um and they brought with them a phalanx
of
scientific witnesses who testified to us
that
we don't have to worry about climate
change and
it was such a relief to hear this
because they told us that the climate
was not going to change
or that if it did change it was only
really going to happen in very small
ways
that we were going to enjoy
and i have to tell you there was a part
of me that really wanted to believe them
even though my client the minnesota
pollution control agency was taking just
the opposite view
and um
so i you know tried to resist the lure
of of the more comfortable view being
put forth by the coal industry and of
course the easy way to do that was to
take a look at the evidence which
already by then was so compelling much
too compelling to just wish away
i should say that i'm i'm proud of
minnesota's decision makers they did a
very good job of resisting the the
rosier predictions of the coal industry
accepting instead the much more
disturbing projections of the other
thousands of mainstream scientists those
scientists that the entire rest of the
world is depending on
it's too soon to say really what effect
that proceeding had on minnesota but it
had a really profound effect on me for
the first time i had really focused on
coal in the aggregate
and
i was astonished to realize what kind of
a large effect it was still having on
air quality after centuries it turns out
of effort to try to deal with that
and at the growing effect it was having
on the climate which is a problem we
have not even begun to address at least
not in this country
so i decided to do a little research
particularly into the history and i have
to say it's when i got to the history of
this fuel that i got really hooked and i
stopped thinking of that history as just
the background to
what's going on with coal today i
started realizing that what's happening
now
is really the very dramatic culmination
of a long centuries long story
and then i quit my job
and put aside my law career to write a
book about coal
now a word about the title
cole
it took years for us to come up with
that title it wasn't that we didn't have
other ideas there were lots of other
ideas but they didn't
quite capture it so we went with the
short and sweet and succinct um
the subtitle is a human history and
it's not perhaps the most accurate a
more accurate title might have been
something like a natural and social and
political and environmental and cultural
history with a discussion of current
events and some predictions about the
future um yeah that was a little long i
i like a human history for a couple of
reasons one because it suggests
things it has it has very large
implications and this is a story with
large implications but also it has
implications that are very small and
personal and while i've tried to tell a
large story i've tried to do it through
very small readable
vignettes and anecdotes about how this
substance has affected people's
day-to-day lives now for centuries
i discovered in my research that
attitudes about coal have varied
tremendously over the centuries and from
society to society which is perhaps not
surprising
some of the first people to really value
coal didn't value it because of its heat
content they valued it because of its
beauty
i have my lump here
never leave home without it
in fact we have records of neolithic
chinese thousands of years ago who
found coal this is actually chinese coal
but probably not the same they used
who carved coal into what
archaeologists have labeled
ear piercing ornaments so apparently
they were wearing coal in their ears we
know that the romans when they went to
britain were uh wrote back to rome and
talked about the best stone in britain
and it was coal but the reason they
really liked it was because they could
carve it into ornaments and it became
something of a fashion trend in rome to
have these shiny black and flammable
ornaments
now
of course after it was prized for its
beauty much later it became basically
just the epitome of disappointment it
was what you would find in your
christmas talking if you had been bad
there were other times in history in
fact quite a long stretch of history
where coal was perceived as something
really quite evil it smelled for one
thing of brimstone which is what we call
sulfur it was mined in these scary
subterranean places and it was widely
perceived that those mines were haunted
by demons
but later on in history it came to be
seen as really the foundation
of civilization itself it became seen as
a gift from god sent to help lift up
civilization
there's one
quote in particular here that i like
very succinct this is a writer from the
early 20th century who said with coal
and he capitalizes coal this is from a
great little book called the coal
catechism
he said with coal we have light strength
power wealth and civilization
without coal we have darkness weakness
poverty and barbarism
another writer put it uh you used i
think a little more complicated metaphor
and that was it was that of the genie to
describe coal and i like that metaphor
and i use it in the book because
coal like a genie has indeed granted
many of our wishes it has empowered us
in tremendous ways it has made many of
us in developed nations wealthy beyond
our pre-industrial dreams
but like a genie it has a dark and
unpredictable side and we have paid
throughout history and well into the
future a very high price
for that power but i wanted to try to
capture in this book both sides of it
both the sort of creative and the
destructive side of it because i think
if you miss one of those sides you're
not going to really understand our
history and you're not really going to
understand the challenges that we face
now here are some of the things that i'd
like to cover today
how coal turned britain into a global
superpower how coal not only fueled the
industrial revolution but inspired the
creation
of the two most revolutionary
technologies the steam engine and the
railway
how coal created whole new social
classes of people promoting both the
rise of industrial capitalism and the
rise of communism how coal helped tame
the american wilderness win the civil
war pushed the frontier westward how
coal set the pattern for concentrated
corporate power and public mistrust of
that power how coal shaped the u.s labor
movement how fighting coal smoke was a
major part of the early environmental
movement how cold today is quite
probably killing thousands of americans
yearly how coal is promoting the very
dangerous and permanent warming of our
climate how the coal industry is
celebrating new political power in
america and how coal use today is
revealing geopolitical rifts between
america and most of the rest of the
world
but of course i'm not really going to
cover any of that
uh because it's way too much and we have
only a few minutes so what i'm going to
do instead and let me say that that is
all covered in coal a human history
so what i'm going to do instead is read
a few small sections from the book that
will hopefully give you an idea of what
is inside i write a great deal about
britain
because britain really was the first
society not the first to burn it because
that was china but the first society to
be really permanently transformed by
coal of course what happened was coal
carried britain over that all-important
threshold between the pre-industrial
world and the industrial world the
consequences were momentous economically
socially and environmentally
particularly in places like london
london had long been known for its fogs
including occasional great stinking fogs
as one 17th century astronomer called
them in his weather records
there was though a marked increase in
the frequency of london fogs between
1750 and 1890 natural climate
fluctuations could have contributed to
the increase but inevitably so did the
smoke
the city could barely be seen from above
such as from the top of st paul's
cathedral
lord byron described the london skyline
as a wilderness of steeples peeping on
tiptoe through their sea coal canopy
smoke was such a quintessential part of
london that for a long time the city
held the nickname the big smoke
while the fogs were unnatural they could
also be beautiful
many residents and visitors looked on
the smoke as picturesque enhancing the
mystery and excitement of the city
perhaps one reason why 19th century
efforts to clean the city's heir for
such a failure
british writers called the thick air
london's sublime canopy that shrouds the
city of the world
and referred to their beloved smoke
indeed although some travelers from
abroad were appalled by the smoke many
others were charmed by it a canadian
visitor writing late in the century said
that the comforting smoke
gave a kind of solidity and nutriment to
the air and made you feel as if your
lungs digested it
in contrast to her monotonously clean
home
in 1883 an american poet living in
london wrote today we are having a
yellow fog and that always enlivens me
it has such a knack of transfiguring
things even the cabs are rimmed with a
halo and people across the way have all
that possibility of suggestion which
peaks the fancy so in figures of fading
frescoes
even the gray even the black fogs make a
new and unexplored world not unpleasing
to one who is getting palled with
familiar landscapes
i'm quote for reasons we still don't
understand london's fogs were more
frequently being reported as strangely
colored including the occasional orange
and dark chocolate fogs
with all its potential for aesthetic
appeal it's quite clear that the
pollution of victorian london could
bring confusion and death particularly
when a dense fog planted itself over the
city for three or more days
on a wednesday in december 1873 for
example a thick cold fog settled in and
stayed until the following saturday
at one point stretching 50 miles from
the city
visibility was reduced to a few yards
and according to the brief articles
printed in the weather section of the
times all locomotion especially to
people on foot at the crossings of great
thoroughfares became extremely dangerous
the fog was blamed for a sad and chaotic
parade of sometimes fatal accidents that
left the hospitals straining to care for
the injures injured
carriages crashed into light posts and
other obstacles people were run over by
omnibuses and handsome cabs one poor
fellow was run over by both
horses tripped and crushed their riders
and a train struck a man who was putting
fog lights along the track
the police were kept busy trying to
handle the multitude of lost children
the most common reported fog related
deaths were the 20 drownings that took
place over the four day period caused
when people simply stumbled into the
thames or the canals of the city or when
barge collisions threw them into the
water
the paper failed to report that several
cattle in the city for an exhibition
dropped dead in the fog and many others
were in such distress that they had to
be immediately slaughtered
amidst the various locomotion related
deaths the times also noted the deaths
of two gentlemen who had in separate
incidents fell in the street and shortly
died from inhaling the fog
in reporting just these two deaths by
inhalation the times was off by two
orders of magnitude an analysis of the
city's death statistics performed
decades later showed that the 1873 fog
quietly killed from 270 to 700 londoners
another foggy week in 1880 would kill
from 700 to 1100 people and one in 1892
would kill about a thousand
these deaths went largely unreported
while people worried instead about the
far less deadly but more dramatic
confusion in the streets
19th century londoners probably had the
statistical skills to detect these
deaths long before they actually did if
they had only looked
perhaps they didn't look because they
had been living for so long in a fog of
their own making that they simply took
it for granted
they stopped asking the harder questions
about the impact this unnatural new
world
they'd created so energetically was
having on its human inhabitants
this
was just one of the traits that along
with coal put the british at the
vanguard of the industrial revolution
others included the desire to conquer
nature
of faith in technology
a belief in private enterprise
tolerance for the misery of the working
class
and a conviction that their nation had a
larger destiny as a world power
of course across the atlantic there was
another nation that shared all these
traits and that had even more coal
and it was undergoing an even more
astonishing transformation
and of course that transformation was
the change from a
heavily forested near wilderness into an
industrial superpower and it was
happening very quickly as early as the
late 1700s people in philadelphia found
the price of firewood going up and that
was because the trees nearby had already
been consumed industries in philadelphia
actually imported bituminous coal soft
coal sometimes from as far as britain
to meet their needs now there's a
tremendous irony here because
pennsylvania
is loaded with coal bituminous on the
west and on the east there is a very
hard form of coal clean burning kind of
coal called anthracite
but that anthracite was was trapped up
in the mountains and it was very
difficult to get down to the city
doesn't mean people didn't try though
and in fact people
in the late 1700s early 1800s would go
up to this anthracite region cut down
some of those trees and make these long
flat boats out of the wood they called
them arcs
and they would load them up with coal
put four or five people on each one and
send it down the lehigh river hoping
several days later to arrive in
philadelphia the lehigh river at the
time was quite wild so in essence these
people were shooting the rapids in their
coal boats trying to get to the market
there were a couple of problems
most of the ships crashed and sank that
was one problem
the other problem was that the ones that
made it through
were not wanted this was hard coal some
people called it stone coal and a lot of
people really didn't think it could burn
because it was much harder to ignite
than the kind of bituminous coal they
were used to burning there was one great
quote from a
very frustrated customer who had tried
to use some of this anthracite and he
said that if the world should ever take
fire the lehigh coal mine would be the
safest retreat the last place to burn
and what makes it particularly funny is
that um within a few years in fact the
lehigh coal mine took fire and it burned
without anyone being able to stop it for
82 years
so he was wrong about that being the
best place uh but in the meantime nobody
quite knew what to do with uh with this
anthracite coal in fact one of the
shipments that made it through in 1803
they paved the foot walks with it
because
they just couldn't quite figure it out
but of course that was not the end for
the u.s the would-be u.s coal industry
there was another effort that i'd like
to read about
despite this failure in a few years
there would be another bold effort to
bring summit hill coal that's the
anthracite down to the city this one to
relieve a shortage of imported
bituminous caused by the war of 1812.
to seize the opportunity presented by
the war a well-educated and connected
man named jacob sist leased the summit
hill mine with some partners
instead of hiring farmers near the mine
syst chose to bring in a labor force
from his home of wilkes-barre a town
well north of the mine
he gathered a small but enthusiastic
army mainly composed of boys from the
area's most prominent families and in
july 1814 they marched off as if to war
amidst much fanfare and singing
they had no experience in coal mining
arc building or rapids running
but they did include a good latin
scholar
a natural-born poet and one young man
principally noted for his musical powers
one of this workforce would later say of
syst and his partners the whole thing
was a romance there was a chance here
was a chance for adventure well suited
to their prolific imaginations beside an
eternity of glorious posthumous fame
in august they managed to send four arks
loaded with coal down the lehigh three
of them sank
when a rock ledge tore a hole in the
bottom of the fourth it looked as if the
end was near but its crew of six quickly
stripped off their clothes stuffed them
in the hole and kept the ark afloat
these gentlemen of wilkes-barre arrived
in philadelphia several days later
nearly naked bruised blackened with coal
dust and glad to be alive according to
cyst was among them
now sis and his partners never really
were able to make anything out of that
coal mine
it uh went under they had to sell it
after the war but they did get a little
bit of the fame they sought because they
sold that heroically delivered shipment
of coal to a couple of industrialists in
philadelphia who went on then to invest
in the area and to really kind of open
it up by uh
taming the lehigh river and then going
in and bringing in canals and railroads
the region itself
went on to become the site of the
nation's first major land rush
its first major canal and railroad
systems its first major corporate cartel
and some of the bloodiest labor
relations in u.s history this is the
area where the famous molly maguires
once worked the molly mcguires were
allegedly
a secret society of irish catholic coal
mining terrorists
and this is where the the prosecution
that was essentially controlled in fact
consisted of
the the railroads that control the area
tried and tried the molly mcguires and
had them hanged
by 1900 america became the world's top
producer of coal drawing on coal from
lots of different states and of course
it became an industrial powerhouse as a
result
i also have a chapter in the book about
china
china turns out to be incredibly
important to this story for a lot of
reasons for one thing it has the oldest
history of coal mining and coal pops up
at all kinds of amazing
places in china's amazing history it is
also of all the major nations right now
the one that is by far the most
dependent on coal
they have lots of coal they have lots of
people and they have a very fast-growing
economy and they're counting on their
coal to help them bring electricity to
the hundreds of millions of people there
who either don't have it or don't have
very much of it
another thing that makes china important
is that when the bush administration
talks about why america is not going to
sign the kyoto protocol which is the
treaty to reduce greenhouse gases
one of the common reasons is because it
wouldn't be fair for america to have to
reduce its greenhouse gases
when countries developing countries and
particularly like china
don't have to reduce theirs and in fact
that puts america and china
in a very strange little club together
these two countries burn more coal than
anyone else in the world in fact about
the same amount depending on whose
numbers you believe not on a per capita
basis but on an absolute basis and both
countries reserve the right to burn a
lot more and and plan to do so
so i went to china
to research the book and that's where my
next excerpt is
if you get on a train in beijing
and travel a couple of days west through
the mountains and toward the center of
the vast asian land mass you will find
yourself in inner mongolia's forbidding
ordos desert
i made this journey not long ago as i
looked out the train window i was struck
by the emptiness of the land
reminder of how far i was from the
crowded bustle of coastal china
there was the occasional lone herdsmen
guiding a few forlorn looking sheep
it was a mystery to me how the few tufts
of grass and brush clinging to the
yellow sand and rocky hills could yield
enough energy to support any animals at
all
here and there the smoke stacks of
isolated factories rose up out of the
desert but it was no mystery where they
got their energy
it was from the jungles that once grew
here and that bequeathed to china coal
deposits richer than those of any other
nation except the united states
i was traveling with a young
english-speaking chinese woman from
beijing whom i will call jane
not only did jane prove to be a highly
capable guide and translator but she had
a charm that could get us into places i
could have never otherwise seen
and when needed get us out again
one such place was a coal burning power
plant outside a small city in the ordos
this plant used the same basic
generating technology as the shurco
plant in minnesota a few miles north of
here
and was about the same age but it was
far smaller and already slightly
bedraggled
a window had been broken and left
unfixed
so many interior lights had burned out
that it was hard to see the electric
generator
i saw more people at this small plant
than at the much larger american one but
none appeared to be working at the time
rather they gathered in groups of four
and five to watch me
smiling and occasionally shouting out in
english hello
they laughed heartily when i tried to
respond in chinese
jane explained that although two western
men had visited the city years before
i was the first western woman most of
these people had ever seen in person
remote as it is
this corner of inner mongolia like the
rest of china is ready for the outside
world to discover it
the city's top hotel may have hot water
for only one hour a day by
pre-arrangement so they can crank up the
coal-fired boiler
but behind the front desk a bank of
clocks helpfully gives the time in major
foreign cities such as london and new
york
the power plant official who showed us
around
had been told only that i was an
american tourist with an unusual
fascination for call
which was true enough as far as it went
i i wondered why he even let us in
but then it became awkwardly clear that
he believed i represented foreign
investors who might be willing to pump
some much needed capital into his
facility
as we left this plant our taxi driver
said he had a friend at another power
plant we could visit a few miles away
when we arrived our driver boldly led us
through the gates and onto the grounds
before we could find our driver's friend
we heard shouting
a man of evident authority ran up and
began yelling at me in chinese
as i looked around nervously imagining
our imminent arrest jane smiled and
reassured him with some friendly banter
that i was harmless and he calmed down
we left quickly
jane told me later that the man had
accused me of being there to document
pollution to embarrass china for
political reasons
it would have been far harder to explain
to him the more complicated truth
the very different reactions to my
presence at these two power plants
reflect the conflicting feelings the
chinese have toward the outside world
years of isolation and the economic
disasters of decades past
have brought a genuine eagerness to
connect with other nations along with a
strong reluctance to be judged by their
standards especially environmental
standards that rich nations did not
embrace until they were rich
these are sentiments best understood in
the larger context of china's ancient
glories its humiliation at the hands of
the west and its desperate 20th century
attempts to modernize
aspects of chinese history that
prominently feature coal
and that's uh what else i i write about
in that chapter
finally i would like to talk a little
more about climate change
and why it's so important to the story
of coal and to the story of everything
else
coal is mostly carbon and when you burn
that carbonate turns into carbon dioxide
a greenhouse gas which is building up in
our atmosphere and which is going to be
lingering now for centuries trapping
heat on earth now
you also get carbon dioxide when you
burn petroleum which is a very big
problem and when you burn natural gas
which is a smaller problem but coal
because it has so much carbon gives you
by far the most carbon dioxide for the
amount of energy you get out of it so
that that's what makes it the most
climate unfriendly
of all the fossil fuels
and that's why the coal industry is very
concerned about climate change policies
and has worked very hard to make sure
that we don't have any and they're very
pleased that the bush administration has
been steadfast in avoiding any kind of
mandatory greenhouse gas controls
they by the way played a a really fairly
decisive role in getting him elected
of course in the meantime our emissions
continue to rise
and so does the average temperature of
the planet 2002 was the second warmest
year in history 1990s with the second or
the warmest decade
probably in a thousand years we've got
glaciers melting on nearly every
continent we've got the north polar ice
cap shrinking dramatically we have
chunks of ice the size of
small nations
breaking off of the ice shelves of
antarctica
all of this and even more frightening
projections for the future
have persuaded the rest of the developed
world to go forward without us
on the kyoto protocol it's probable that
this summer that is going to go into
effect and these other nations which are
already generally much more fuel
efficient than we are are going to be
taking even more steps away from a
dependency on fossil fuel america by
contrast the largest greenhouse gas
producer in the world the source of some
25 percent of greenhouse gases
continues to burn ever more fossil fuel
so i i honestly don't think this
situation can last too much longer i
think if only because of the
international pressure we are going to
have to be taking climate change
seriously
fairly soon
and that raises the question what about
coal does that mean the end of of this
long story of coal use on earth now if
you ask the coal industry that
what they'll tell you is that
not necessarily and just in case we ever
have to reduce greenhouse gases not that
we have to but in case we ever decide
later that we have to they're working on
a long-term plan to try to make coal
more palatable and the name of the
approach is carbon sequestration the
idea is that they're going to try to
collect
the carbon dioxide that's spewing out of
all the smoke stacks
and tuck it away uh somewhere in the in
the earth now this actually might be
an acceptable idea if if they were
talking about it as a way of
retrofitting
existing coal plants
so that you could then
keep operating them until you were able
to build a more kind of sustainable and
clean system but
nobody's really imagined a way that you
can retrofit the existing coal plants
what they're talking about instead is
actually redesigning coal plants so the
carbon dioxide stream is more
concentrated
rebuilding all of our fleet of coal
plants now of course talking about some
decades in the future
and building an infrastructure where you
would collect that carbon dioxide
transport it and dispose of it now
where do you put it there's been talk
about using abandoned oil wells about a
ban using abandoned coal mines but it
seems quite likely that there are not
going to be nearly enough of those kinds
of geologic formations to hold the
spectacular quantities of carbon dioxide
that we would be talking about so
uh they're also looking and by they i
mean the coal industry in the department
of energy
at the deep oceans
um at essentially pumping carbon dioxide
down there to essentially carbonating
those parts
of the oceans this obviously is
something that has the potential for for
tremendous environmental consequences
and people who know about the plan
tend to be pretty worried about it
ultimately i don't think it will happen
uh because in fact we do have better
options in the realm of renewables like
wind and solar and if you combine them
with a system of hydrogen production
which allows you then to store and
distribute energy you could actually
have a system you could finally have a
system that is truly clean and truly
renewable and
i think that's the way we're more likely
to go
though perhaps because i'm an optimist
by nature
which brings me to my last excerpt
in imagining possible futures it's
important to factor in one last critical
energy source
excitement
there was a time when coal was actually
fun
not the mining which was never fun but
the building of a powerful new
coal-fired world which inspired distinct
bursts of imagination
enthusiasm and daring at various
historical moments
matthew bolton's excitement over his
partner james watts steam engine came
from his belief in it as the key to
building a magnificent new society of
unlimited possibilities
george stevenson was surely thrilled to
zoom across the english landscape at
speeds never before reached on railways
he knew would transform the nation and
the planet
jacob's sist and his young crew shot the
rapids of pennsylvania's lehigh river on
flimsy arcs filled with coal mainly for
the glory and adventure of helping
create a new industry to fuel a new
world
even franklin b gowan when he organized
the anthracite cartel in the name of
empowering a growing nation was probably
having an excellent time
today though the thrill of coal is gone
and it's not likely to come back even if
technological breakthroughs can reduce
its environmental impact
bright ambitious people eager to change
the world will be less inspired by the
challenge of building a vast new carbon
sequestration infrastructure
essentially a system of perpetual waste
management than by the challenge of
building completely new energy
industries with no waste at all
enthusiasm and talent will flow more
freely to the new energy industries not
to mention the backing of visionary
financiers and environmentally concerned
investors
most people would simply rather direct
their passion and money toward creating
a new world than toward retrofitting the
old one at least when the old one is as
deeply flawed and widely unloved as your
average coal plant
it is in short hard to imagine that will
ever make the sweeping investments
needed to make coal use truly
sustainable when we appear to have
better and ultimately probably cheaper
options even among the technologies we
already know about
but that still leaves open the question
of when we will have the political will
to abandon the investment we've already
made in coal
and in places like the united states and
china the investments we continue to
make
and with that
i guess i will take your questions um
and if you could wait before you ask for
the for the microphone to come so we can
all hear you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
in
china the smoke coming out of the stacks
would be what color and then at the
united states it's what color and what
would the difference be
in the amount of pollution
coming out of each
good question we by the way have a coal
plant not very far from here the high
bridge plant
and if you look at it especially during
the summer you can't see anything coming
out of it it's hard to even know when
it's on in the winter you'll see big
white plumes coming out in fact that's
mostly smoke
and that plant is not particularly well
controlled is my understanding so it's
even there you have a plant without
scrubbers and you still can't see the
pollution so we've managed in this
country to keep
most of that pollution uh invisible uh
and and we've done that in part by
keeping out the little visible
particulates and whatnot so we we send
out these vast streams of invisible
pollution that then spread a very long
way in china the smoke i saw coming out
of the stacks was was quite dark it was
gray or black
china has a tremendous
pollution problem a tremendous local
pollution problem five out of the ten
filthiest cities in the world are in
china beijing being one of them
and the country is is starting to deal
with that problem but only on a very
local level they haven't even gotten yet
to the regional level but i but i also
want to say that a lot of plants in this
country in america remain uncontrolled
and it's so it's important to keep in
mind that you can have a very polluting
plant and have no visible emissions
coming from it
i just want to say how much i appreciate
your book and i hope that it gets a lot
of attention thank you from a lot of
people and i hope that hopefully the
political leaders will pay some
attention to that if we can get them to
um listen to a lot of us who will
hopefully make them
pay attention to it
but i'm encouraged by your optimism i
hope that what you say israel is
is going to happen and i'm wondering if
you could give us a little more
uh comfort in why you think that we are
going to be able to
um
move forward on alternative energy
sources and you know i hear so much
about you know people are more worried
about nuclear energy now and they say
well that's cleaner than coal so of
course we should use nuclear and we're
all and some of us are really worried
about the nuclear waste issues so i'm
i'm just wondering if you could give us
some more comfort or tell us what we can
do
to ensure that maybe our political
leaders will have some political will
in getting this to happen right and
getting you know the alternative energy
movement to grow that's actually the
easier question yeah
call them write them and vote
accordingly and make sure it becomes an
issue i mean the amazing thing was that
in 2000
you know we never had a clearer choice
between a president who had written a
book about global warming and who had
helped negotiate kyoto and between a
president who represented who had worked
within the oil industry
and of course it was not really an issue
in the 2000 election except in west
virginia where the coal industry helped
deliver the state to george bush and you
know had they not and in fact that's a
traditionally democratic state had they
not been so active in in trying to
prevent gore from becoming president
i think gore would have been president
um it's yeah
uh as far as as my optimism i mean the
good thing is there are a lot of things
going on i mean remember the 70s and we
had renewable energy coming up and and
you know people didn't take it hugely
seriously and we we made a lot of
mistakes but there have been people all
along the way who are continuing to
develop wind and solar
the industry in california sort of kept
chugging along more importantly the
industry in europe kept going and that
technology is now really quite advanced
and it is in fact fairly inexpensive you
can you can get electricity from wind
turbines in in a windy place like like
southwestern minnesota
and it doesn't cost that much more than
what you'd get from a coal plant now
the problem with things like wind and
solar is that not just the cost but
reliability has been an issue
because the wind isn't always blowing
when you want electricity and
electricity we really don't have a way
of storing it you need to generate it
when you need it
and that's why the technology of
hydrogen is considered so promising
hydrogen is not an energy source it is
an energy carrier but what it allows you
to do is you can use the electricity
that you are generating in these windy
distant places on windy days
create hydrogen then you build an
infrastructure to distribute it the way
we have distribution of natural gas and
petroleum right now and then you can use
that hydrogen for a fuel cell car for
fuel cell in your home to meet your own
electricity needs
so that that's certainly a very
promising technology now many of you
heard president bush mentioning hydrogen
at his recent state of the union address
he was talking about it really as a
replacement of foreign oil
but
that is a sign of
i'll call it progress i mean
al gore was raked over the coals for
proposing pretty much exactly the same
thing
not very long ago and and you know it
remains to be seen what kind of
commitment will really get out of the
white house but at least it is now being
talked about people are starting to
envision a post fossil fuel world
and there are so many advantages to it
quite apart from climate change
coal as i mentioned is is putting
pollution in the air that according to
recent studies is killing tens of
thousands of americans quite possibly
thousands and quite possibly tens of
thousands of americans every year now
and you think about just the potential
litigation involved in that and and what
that pollution is coming largely from
these heavy coal burning states in the
midwest ohio river valley type states a
lot of it is blowing east to places like
new york and massachusetts places with
republican governors but they're very
angry about this and they're promoting
renewable energy within their own states
as a result so what i'm hoping is going
to build the momentum is the fact that
the costs are already coming down
europe is already going ahead to
continue developing the technology
hopefully that will bring the costs down
even further
and there are so many other reasons that
relate very directly to our lifestyles
and our health
that i'm i'm just very hopeful that the
ball will start rolling
you don't look convinced however
let's have a question given
the health costs and the people that die
from
the results of coal-fired power plants
and the fact that so many uh power
plants and uh coal fire burners are are
don't have any pollution control on them
like in minnesota we have 60 coal-fired
boilers and four of them have pollution
control
now given that um
all over 60 or almost 60 percent of
electricity is generated by coal don't
we do something about coal
in the interim because these new
technologies are decades away i mean we
can't just jump we can't just can we
address the call problem in the meantime
well that actually you raise a very
important question and um i don't know
that i can answer it i mean at least as
i hear you
to address those problems means
installing lots of expensive control
equipment on those plants and that would
save a lot of lives
and it's so it's very very hard to to
not want to do that on the other hand it
is very very expensive to do that and so
the question becomes
is it worth it to invest a lot in those
sort of interim improvements in a
technology that we're going to
try to abandon
hopefully fairly quickly
and i don't know that i can answer that
it's a question of how we're going to
value our health
what
what sort of improvements we can get for
a certain amount of money vis-a-vis what
we could do if we actually closed down
those plants we could invest by the way
not just in new energy technologies but
in efficiency improvements of course
we're very wasteful in our energy use
and you can get a lot of improvements by
spending that same sort of money to
actually reduce usage and close some of
those plants
it's a hard question to answer though
without a specific scenario in front of
you in the in dollars and cents and
lives and all those really hard things
one more question i used a great analogy
in the book of coal being kind of
captured sunshine or energy that had
rained on the planet
millions of years ago and then had been
stored there and now we're basically
depleting this bank of energy
and then you go to talk about hydrogen
technologies and it takes energy to to
remove the hydrogen from water to
separate it from the oxygen
i'm wondering um i don't know but is
there enough energy raining on the earth
today with wind and solar energy to
actually
separate the hydrogen from oxygen on an
ongoing basis yeah and support the kind
of civilization that we want to be
supporting my understanding is that
there is in fact plenty of that kind of
solar income coming in and what's
interesting of course is that
coal represents
a deviation from our dependency on solar
income we and every other species on the
planet if you don't count certain
microorganisms that live in volcanoes
and things have depended on solar income
for
since life began and coal was this major
threshold where all of the sudden we
didn't just depend on what had just
arrived or what was held in the in the
tissues of the plants and other living
things but we went underground and we
started using this fuel from hundreds of
millions of years before uh and that we
could not have built the society that we
have today had we not been able to do
that but
it may well be now with our technology
or which with our ability to harness
those power sources that that coal in
essence that fossil fuels have given us
the ability
to live based on solar income so that in
fact we don't need coal or someday even
oil anymore
uh what are your choices regarding
yourself as an energy consumer uh are
you an exemplar of uh
using wind power in in your day-to-day
activity i am not i am a sinner with
everyone else i am waiting for uh my
local power company to offer me green
power and in fact that is something
they're supposed to be offering soon but
they haven't offered it yet and as soon
as they do then i'll certainly pay a
premium to get that in the meantime
try to keep the lights off when i don't
need them
well i'm from pennsylvania originally so
you don't need to convince me of how
important coal has been in the history
of this country
and i just wanted to say that i brought
with me tonight some genuine examples of
pennsylvania anthracite
in a bucket here i don't have enough for
everybody but i'm gonna pass around
it's a found in a slate matrix so the
kind of light gray dull part is the
slate but the bright shiny pretty part
is the coal and you mentioned at the
very beginning of your talk about how
beautiful coal can be
and it is it's clean you can you know
rub it on your white shirt it won't
leave a streak it's
it's pretty and that's the good stuff so
i have some
lumps of genuine pennsylvania
i'm gonna pass around that's great and
take some but my question that i wanted
to raise was the contribution of coal to
culture
and uh
you know people don't write like songs
about uh you know oil the review of your
book in the uh in the sunday strip
talked about how glamorous oil is and
how unglamorous coal is but if you think
about the contributions to music and
poetry and novels that coal has made
versus oil
in our culture this is no comparison
that's right
you know people uh
i i'm a folk music fan and just uh
this afternoon thinking about what you
know songs about coal you know there's
lots of them i could come up with you
know dark is a dungeon and 16 tons and
coal tattoo and coal miners daughter and
on and on and on and i could only think
of one song on the night of all the folk
songs i know that was written about oil
and that's a song called the shores of
prudo bay
written by bill stains in 1988 so it's
not a really traditional photo that's
not old enough so you know maybe cool is
not very glamorous but there's lots of
great songs it has it has given us a lot
of great songs and a lot of great
culture and of course that's pretty much
a direct reflection of the amount of
suffering that he just caused
and i guess i'm not convinced that
that's a real good reason to keep
burning it but it will be a loss
when we lose those songs maybe somebody
will write some hydrogen songs but i'm
not persuaded they'll be very good
we can still sing about cole we'll love
it even more when it's gone
hi
uh
25 years ago when i was in college
as an engineer
one of my professors stood up and said
well in the in the course of the lecture
series said that
you know he didn't really think of very
poorly of nuclear energy but he
certainly was opposed to coal energy
because of the pollution dangers
and
you know him saying that at that time
was a little bit different
thing about that now i wonder if you
yourself sometimes have thought that
coal
or that nuclear energy and some of the
things about it have um
kind of kept coal going
to our disadvantage
well that's a really good question i
think you're right yeah do you have
another question well
um the other question would be asthma
and the incidence in children
could there be any relationship any
corollary between that and
greenhouse gases and things have you
ever heard about i'm not not sure if
it's from greenhouse gases but there
certainly is a correlation between
asthma especially in children and ozone
and ozone
you've heard about the ozone layer
there's a problem in the stratosphere
where we don't have enough ozone but we
have a problem down here where we have
too much ozone and ozone definitely
triggers asthma attacks and ozone comes
not out of any smoke stack but it's a
combination of pollutants and one of the
critical ingredients is nitrogen oxides
which come from coal also from cars but
coal is a major contributor to that so
yes there would be a very direct link
between asthma particularly childhood
asthma and emissions from a coal plant i
like your question about nuclear power
and coal we have been of course worried
about nuclear power and with good reason
for a long time but you know i think in
comparison particularly to nuclear power
which is so modern and scary
coal just seems so old-fashioned and
friendly you know and how could coal be
doing all this damage
you know it's it's unfortunate that we
can't seem to worry about more than one
thing at a time
my name is elizabeth dickinson and i am
with a group called clean energy now
who have been working to try and clean
up the local coal burning facilities
there is a really exciting program that
i need people's help with because people
were asking what they can do to help
clean them up
excel has a voluntary program that's
going to the public utilities commission
to transform two of the local coal
burning facilities including the high
bridge here in st paul and the riverside
in minneapolis
uh to natural gas
and they're also going to put pollution
control equipment on the stillwater
plant the king plant in stillwater
but it's going to the public utilities
commission which makes the final
decision they're taking public
commentary up until february 21st
i have some petitions and i have some
sample letters and i would encourage
everyone here to
to sign them
so that we can show that there's a lot
of community support this is really huge
because in the 30 years since the clean
air act came out
only three coal burning facilities in
the entire united states have ever gone
over to gas
we don't believe gas is the final option
but it's the cleanest out of all of the
things that excel was considering and it
what virtually wipes out the nitrogen
oxides the sulfur dioxides
um it eliminates the mercury which i
know you haven't said very much about
and it cuts the carbon dioxide in half
it's just very very exciting and there's
not been a lot been a lot of attention
paid to it so i would really love your
support and i will send the petition
around and i have fact sheets if you
want to look at them thank you that will
be a nice improvement
um you were talking about coal songs
there are a lot of very beautiful songs
about the sun and the wind
ah right good point
and to respond to the question about uh
requiring pollution control of coal
plants one of the important parts about
that in addition to saving lives is it
makes the cost of coal
be more commensurate with what it
actually does and that uh that margin of
difference is enough to make renewable
energy
competitive in the in the economic
market um i work with elizabeth and i
have worked together i'm i run the
sierra clubs program to reduce air
pollution in minnesota and we do a lot
of work with coal and renewable energy
our organizer of course always
with the people way in the back wave
your hand but if you want if you're
interested in working on
reducing coal plant pollution there
there's legislation that people are
working on there's the project to
convert excel there are also specific
programs to try and encourage wind and
and right now also in minnesota
agricultural energy that is renewable
and the one thing i would say that maybe
people say what is it that's going to
make this happen i think they're
developing some real important
self-interest
among people who see that it's the
health of their child but also among
people in western minnesota who see it's
the survival of their farm
and i think if we're saying where does
the hope come from it comes from
enlightened self-interest which is what
this country is based on
so there's still some hope and please um
either let elizabeth or michelle or i
have your name and phone and email and
we will bother you as much as you'd like
coming up work on this
thank you
as
i really i think your book will be a
major
contribution to sort of how we got to
the
industrial age uh we're at today in over
200 years
um i guess a couple i don't i haven't i
want to read your book but a couple of
things uh
i wonder if you touch it all on on the
sort of the strides made after the clean
air act and what was in 1978
and i think minnesota gets something
like 60 percent of its energy comes from
the coal fields in north dakota and
montana
and i understand that you know the
plants that were built out there in the
70s to provide us with the electricity
and air conditioning we have today all
meet the clean air standards and and i
was involved in government out there and
and uh hundreds of millions of dollars
were spent for scrubbers electrostatic
precipitators and all those kinds of
things
could a lot of the coal other coal
plants in the country
you know be retrofitted there's a
coal gasification plant out there which
is essentially synthetic natural gas and
isn't that an oxymoron synthetic natural
gas
but uh
you know i guess
you know we may go be going to war in
the middle east over oil or energy and i
mean here we have coal
and so instead of importing oil you know
are there things that we can do
additionally with new technology
to make you know as as the newer coal
plants i think out in north dakota and
montana indicate where they do meet the
very strictest epa standards uh you know
is is there potential to do things like
that can we make it all can we make it
work somehow um
the problem with the control
technologies is that they
will deal with the kind of pollutants
that contribute to acid rain and that
get in your lungs and and can kill you
and ozone and and mercury
but they don't deal with the greenhouse
gases and in fact it's possible that you
can even make the problem a little bit
worse by making that plant slightly less
efficient
so that there's more greenhouse gases
per unit per kilowatt coming out of the
plant now
one way that you can improve their their
climate performance is by improving
efficiency coal gasification is one way
to do that uh again that gets so back to
the interim investment question how much
money do we want to build to make coal
gasification plants
when in fact we might spend that money
on on truly renewable sources
and i'm glad you raised the middle east
because i know a lot of people are
thinking about that a lot of people are
thinking about oil
and the last time we had a big oil
crisis people started talking about coal
and the idea was we were going to make
liquid fuels out of coal and that is
possible
but we haven't done it i think there's
maybe one sort of experimental plant out
there despite investments and tax
incentives and whatnot it just hasn't
happened so that means that it's not
likely i think to be a short-term
solution just because we don't have the
infrastructure in place to give us a
significant amount of of liquid fuel
and i'd and i don't see it as a
long-term solution
simply because it doesn't address
climate change and i think it's going to
be unlikely that we're going to be
pouring a lot of money into any energy
technologies
again this is perhaps the optimist to be
coming out but to spend a lot of money
building a new infrastructure that may
solve your supply problem but which
doesn't solve your climate change
problem seems like a bad investment
barbara freeze was minnesota's assistant
attorney general for 12 years
coal a human history is published by
perseus on the web at
perseuspublishing.com
next week on history on book tv are